okay we talked about
your love for proving that something is
impossible
so there's quite a few still open
problems and complexity
of algorithms uh so let me ask does p
equal
np probably not probably not
if p equals np
what kind of you know and you'd be
really surprised somebody proves it
yeah what would that proof look like and
why would that even be
what would that mean what would that
proof look like
in what possible universe could p equals
np is there something insightful you can
say there
it could it could be true and i mean i'm
not a complexity theorist but every
complexity theorist i know
is convinced they're not equal and are
basically not working on anymore i mean
there is a million dollars at stake if
you can if you can solve the proof it's
one of the millennium prizes
okay so here here's how i think the p
not equals mp proof is going to
eventually happen
i think it's going to fall out and it's
going to be not
super simple but not as hard as people
think because my
my theory about a lot of theoretical
computer science based on just some
results i've done so this is a huge
extrapolation is that
a lot of what we're doing is just
obfuscating deeper mathematics
so like this happens to me a lot not a
lot but it's happened to me a few times
in my work where
yeah we obfuscate it because we say well
there's an algorithm and has this much
you know memory and they're connected on
a network and okay here's our setup and
now we're trying to see how fast it can
solve a problem
and people do bounds about it and in the
end it turns out that like we were just
obfuscating some underlying
you know uh mathematical thing that
already existed
right so this has happened to me i i had
this paper i was quite fond of a while
ago
it was looking at this problem called
contention resolution where
you you you put an unknown set of people
on a shared channel
and they're trying to break symmetry so
it's like an ethernet whatever only one
person can use it at a time you try to
break symmetry there's all these bounds
people have proven over the years
about how long it takes to do this right
and
like i discovered at some point there's
this one
combinatorial result from the early
1990s
all of these lower bound proofs all come
from this and in fact it improved a lot
of them and simplified a lot you could
put it all in one paper
you know it's like are we really and
then okay so this new paper that i
i submitted a couple weeks ago i found
you could take some of these same lower
bound
proofs for this contention resolution
problem you could reprove them
using shannon's source code theorem that
actually when you're breaking contention
what you're really doing
is building a code over uh you know
if you have a distribution on the
network sizes it's a code over that
source
and if you plug in a high entropy
information source and plug in from 1948
the source code theorem that says on a
noiseless channel you can't send things
at a faster rate than the entropy allows
the exact same lower bounds fall back
out again right so like this type of
thing happens there's a there's some
famous lower bounds and
distributed algorithms that turned out
to all be algebraic topology underneath
the covers
and they won the girdle prize for
working on that so my sense is what's
going to happen is at some point
someone really smart to be very exciting
is going to realize there's some sort of
other representation of what's going on
with these turing machines trying to
sort of efficiently fall out of that and
there'll be an existing
mathematical result that applies someone
or something i guess it could be
ai theorem proverbs kind of thing it
could be yeah i mean not a
well yeah i mean there's theorem provers
like what that means now
which is not fun it's just a bunch of
very carefully formulated postulates
that but i take your point yeah
you